allora dunque il coraggio quando quando
pensiamo al coraggio nel nostro campo
che quello della musica pensiamo a
all'idea di avanguardia ma soprattutto a
un'altra cosa allora mi veniva in mente
un vecchissimo libro che si chiamava il
ramo d'oro in cui c'era un antropologo
di nome fraser narrava di un vecchio
rito si svolgeva nel bosco di nemi
vicino all'uomo in cui per tradizione
c'era un re con questo bosco e un certo
punto dopo quando lei si era fatto
vecchio arrivava un pretendente lo
uccideva e diventa valore ora di questo
avrebbe bisogno della musica non di
violenza fisica ma della violenza delle
idee che oggi invece è un po come dire
ora menga tra l'altro il ramo d'oro è
l'equilibrio per capire anche la la
potenza del mito se vi ricordate
apocalypse now the lo ricorda loro isola
dove c'era ma l'ombra ndaw corse che era
ha ricreato nella giungla vietnamita una
specie di mosca e le vedi quel bosco
guarda caso sul tavolo se ci fate caso
nel fotogramma ha proprio il ramo d'oro
di fraser quindi per questo quando
arriva martin sheen di qualche modo è
consapevole che deve essere ucciso
perché così è la natura così è la
tradizione agricola da voi che
significavano original la musica delle
bisogno di questo oggi questo è il
problema
non c'è nessuno disposto ad ucciderla e
per questo fa molta fatica a rinnovarsi
ma in passato e questa oggi
racconteremo brevemente molti e fateci
caso
ogni volta che la musica ha avuto degli
enormi i salti evolutivi dirompenti
rivoluzionari c'è stato qualcuno
disposto ad ucciderlo
voi è probabile che il personaggio
abbiamo sentito nominare
di sicuro un sacco di volte john cage un
musicista d'avanguardia definire
musicista forse abbastanza poco ma
insomma
pensate che quasi tutta la musica che
voi ascoltate oggi deve qualcosa a lui
perché
negli anni cinquanta lui è arrivato un
lunghissimo percorso ovviamente e ha
fatto qualcosa che gli altri non ho mai
fatto prima a con enorme coraggio messo
in scena qualcosa che noi tutti
conosciamo per primi e ha chiesto agli
ascoltatori di avere lo stesso coraggio
non soltanto il coraggio del musicista
adesso vedrete in scena a mettere
eseguire quest'opera straordinaria 433
il nome è dovuto alla durata del pezzo
ma il pezzo non ha diretto una musica
non ha suono e silenzio allo stato puro
quindi il coraggio dell'esecutore il
coraggio il compositore ma soprattutto
il coraggio di gente che si mette
ascoltare una cosa come questa
john cage box
ora questa composizione avanti per 4
minuti e 33 ma il problema che è quello
che john cage ci dice è che dobbiamo
avere coraggio nel provare ad ascoltare
la musica con orecchie diverse energie
siamo circondati dalla musica ascoltiamo
musica dalla mattina alla sera che
quando non vogliamo sua musica dovunque
supermercati ascensori la radio ma è
sempre la stessa musica non c'è mai
nulla che in qualche modo ci sorprenda
qualcosa che ci porti a pensare un'altra
maniera anzi noi chiediamo la musica che
ci faccia pensare il meno possibile ed è
un peccato mortale che il dicendo che
tutto è musica e costringendoci a vedere
un signore fermo davanti a un pianoforte
ci fa pensare a tutto quello che è
possibile fare a quello che noi proviamo
a quello che ci accade dentro in 4
minuti e 33 della nostra vita e pensarci
sù in fin dei conti è un grande atto di
coraggio allora doppia cage però anche a
suo modo ma veniva dal mondo accademico
al mondo la musica contemporanea in cui
comunque in quegli anni la la violenza
delle idee la come viene portata con me
in modo quasi quasi quasi naturale ma la
cosa più straordinaria che cosa ci
interessa di più e quando questi gesti
questi questi momenti sono avvenuti
invece nel campo della musica popolare
cioè quella che teoricamente verso ha
per sua vocazione per sua destinazione
destinata a più gente possibile allora
sì che già l'ha proprio ucciso la musica
maggio sarete radicale cioè addirittura
teorizzando la sua assenza ma guarda
caso proprio in quegli anni la musica
cominciò a cambiare vorticosamente
simbolicamente proprio nel momento in
cui che ci faceva quello nasceva il
rock'n'roll e cominciano a cadere delle
cose poi negli anni sessanta vivo un
signore che si chiama bob dylan il quale
ma insomma se poi dobbiamo pensare al
coraggio in musica direi che forse come
dylan c'è una sola selezionato comunque
pochi altri milan ebbe avuto più volte
coraggio avuto più momenti di estremo
coraggio ma anche per una certezza
questo aiuta
gli artisti quando il coraggio si abbina
molto bene alla la visione cioè al fatto
di avere la certezza che quello che devi
fare è quello e non ci sono altre
possibilità almeno per te di fare
qualcosa di diverso
vino anche salvano c'e l'auto per molti
anni ispirato in modo quasi
sovrannaturale sta di fatto che a un
certo punto lui dopo aver già
rivoluzionato la tradizione folk e aver
cominciato a insegnare a un sacco di
gente nel mondo che fino a quel momento
pensava che la musica pop è una cosa da
ballare su cui divertirci su cui
costruire storie d'amore che invece si
poteva anche solo ascoltare
si poteva passare anche alla musica pop
all'ascolto puro cioè le sue canzoni
chiedevano di essere ascoltate e basta
non di essere ballate o altro ma non
pago di questo mese nei testi in alcune
strutture che sembravano folk testi
assolutamente visionari versati a
tamburo in me per esempio che forse la
più più visionaria di tutte ma a un
certo punto le fece un atto ancora più
dirompente fece un atto dirompente
perché andava a raccontare un pubblico
che il mondo era cambiato
attraverso una canzone provava a
spiegare senza spiegarlo con un discorso
con un con la retorica ma semplice tool
imbracciando uno strumento completamente
diverso da quello che aveva imbracciato
fino a quel momento dalla chitarra
acustica alla chitarra elettrica dal
suono placido del folk quello elettrico
del rock andare a spiegare al pubblico
che voleva essere solo tranquillamente
confermato nelle sue certezze
alternative ci siamo illusi dei duri e
puri della musica folk pensiamo al
popolo americano al cambiamento
siamo impegnati gli andò a dire signori
siete dalla parte sbagliata perché il
mondo si è già spostato e java altrove e
lo fece così
questa questa cosa che fosse stata
definita poi col tempo lo psicodramma
più più violenta più forte che c'è stato
nella storia del rock perché lui andò a
fare questo al festival di newport dove
proprio il luogo uno dei luoghi in cui
era stato beast ha incoronato come il
messia nome sia della musica folk e
tutti aspettavano con la sua chitarra e
la sua armonica a bocca e andò proprio
lì nel 65 a a sconvolgere anche quello
cioè ma non a caso andò a farlo lì nel
tempio della musica folk in quel momento
e fu fischiato la cabina del coraggio
forse se lo immaginava che non
l'avrebbero presa bene ma ormai aveva
deciso doveva fare il folk elettrico e
quella era la strada e che quella fosse
la strada lo sappiamo bene visto che da
quel momento si vuol dire poi che sia
nato veramente il rock tutti tutte le
accezioni che gli diamo allora ascoltare
la musica significa poter immaginare che
il mondo non sia esattamente come noi
immaginiamo che sia non è esattamente
quello ci viene raccontato ascoltare la
musica significa poter aprire gli occhi
su una realtà completamente diversa
ascoltare la musica e non soltanto
consumarla può cambiare la vita da
single a vita probabilmente non tutte le
vite non tutte insieme perché non tutti
ascoltiamo le cose allo stesso modo ma
certamente ognuno di voi ha avuto un
momento in cui una canzone un brano
qualcosa ha spostato il vostro modo di
vedere le cose
lo facciamo sempre di meno lo facciamo
sempre più abitualmente cioè
consideriamo che la musica sia qualcosa
che è con noi ma alla fin fine cambia
poco nelle nostre vite non era così non
è così pensate quando nel 1966 beatles
che erano la band più famosa del mondo
nulla di paragonabile alle
rihanna di oggi quando il ex moglie così
come l'audio non proviamo a dire sì a
partire da canto io destare laica che
sono trovata a tassi sia ancora ancora
posso che dare ai cronisti mi risulterà
molto difficile farvi ascoltare il pezzo
che avremmo dovuto e che forse se la
fortuna ci assiste proviamo a farli
sentire
sì perché la cosa più ancora più
clamoroso di landini la da questa
tradizione folk comunque decise che la
grande poesia americana così poi ha
salutato da dai più attenti in quel
momento da ginsberg e dagli altri poteva
diventare musica ed entrare nei jukebox
ma parlando di coraggio pensiamo a echi
beatles ecco sono sono l'emblema a volte
se come erroneamente pensati come
l'emblema della musica proprio piacevole
più gradevole sono anche quello
intendiamoci ma il video sarà avuto un
coraggio di fronte al quale quello di
dylan e quasi quasi nulla nel senso che
invita a 23 anni avevano fatto già un
successo planetario
vedremo stanotte ha sì sì poi il
coraggio dei leaders e ne parleremo a
lungo
stasera alle officine cantelmo per chi
vorrà venire le dieci e mezzo ma
lì la cosa la grande magia del day 4 b
grazie non accontentarsi mai
cioè in fondo quando non l'ho fatto she
loved che credo sia tuttora il singolo
più venduto della storia della musica
nel 63 64 pezzi alla tattica successi
continui a quel punto per loro è ok
dovevano andare avanti anche il rischio
di perdere quel successo o questa volta
c'è fantasma provate a pensare che siete
nel 66 40 e passa anni fa e oggi sede
radio ricevessero un singolo del genere
sicuramente non lo trasmetterebbero
perché lo riterrebbero troppo di film
allora questa è quella che chiamo la
violenza delle idee appunto cioè il
coraggio di fare qualcosa che per
propria ragione interiori è la cosa
giusta al di là del fatto che possa
piacere per chi è alla mia età o
vagamente se lo ricorda adesso è
difficile ricostruire l'effetto che fece
quel pezzo allora perché poi la musica
questo pezzo la talmente metabolizzato
abbiamo riascoltato il mille altre
musiche ma quando uscì letteralmente non
l'abbiamo capito cioè noi eravamo
affascinati ma c'erano altre canzoni in
quel disco che invece erano più
comprensibili più facile questo era il
finale tiriamo questo disco con questo
pensa che intanto è un pezzo modale
pensate un po nella musica pop un pezzo
fatto con un solo accordo cosiddetto
orizzontale sovrapposizioni cosa alla
rovescia le voci delle parole di due
tibetano dei morti era una roba che
nella musica pop non s'era mai vista per
cui addirittura per capire e
metabolizzare un pezzo così ci volevano
già da qualche mese
pensando al consumo frettoloso di oggi
il passo successivo l'ultimo degli
esempi che però vi andiamo a fare una
cosa che potremmo praticare quasi
quotidianamente non nel modo esatto in
cui lo pratica jimi hendrix e quello
vedremo però l'idea di hendrix a
woodstock quindi nel momento più grande
in cui la cultura alternativa giovanile
dimostrava che un altro mondo era
veramente possibile praticabile arriva
sul palco di gusto e suona l'inno degli
stati uniti d'america
in una condizione normale impianto tutti
avrebbero immaginato un forte lancio di
pomodori ma hendrix prendere il pezzo lo
fa diventare qualcos'altro spiega ai
ragazzi spiega a noi di sicuro a me
sicura gino che se non male vedendo
questo abbiamo anche cambiato il nostro
modo di agire e di pensare e prendete
come cosa e con coraggio fatela
diventare quello che voi volete che sia
non è detto che quello che trovate tutti
i giorni vi possa piacere magari li nome
richiama il vino del vostro paese ma qua
prendetelo e fatelo diventare una cosa
el invenzione pura cioè prendo l'inno
americano di pensate apocalypse now che
citavo prima e sentite le note già piano
piano comincia a distorce perciò è
l'inno americano
roba da poco in quel momento lo comincia
a fare a pezzi a sbriciolarlo non solo
ma a un certo punto e questa è la cosa
che ancora oggi l'ho sentito un milione
e mezzo di volte ma continua ad
emozionarmi e che poi diventa un la
mimesi di un bombardamento indietro cioè
l'inno americano diventa il colpevole
della morte dei vietnamiti che è una
cosa gigantesca pensava che coraggio a
farlo nel 69
insomma andiamo a chiudere dicendo una
cosa abbastanza ovvia
noi dobbiamo cambiare il modo di
ascoltare la musica se noi cambiamo il
modo di ascoltare la musica se abbiamo
il coraggio di ascoltarla in maniera
diversa sicuramente regala musica
migliore e si arriva a musica migliore
il mondo cambia e del migliore non ci
sono dubbi e non è che stiamo riuscendo
una cosa retorica perché il mondo passa
fase migliori basi naturalmente ci sono
corsi ricorsi ma di mettere noi non da
nessun altro e ascoltare la musica non è
una cosa così piccola una pratica così
inutile è una cosa che facciamo tutti i
giorni e che fa parte della nostra vita
quasi come il respiro e quello che
diciamo sempre da noi vengono un sacco
di ragazzi che vogliono fare i
giornalisti scoraggiamo tantissimi che
vogliono fare i musicisti e li
incoraggiamo ma diciamo sempre loro
fatevi avanti come il nuovo re ma per
farlo dovete andare lì del bosco a
uccidere il vecchio rete in carica grano